we have officially passed the 500th day
of 15 days to slow the spread and public
health officials are marking the
occasion
by reinstituting mass orders all around
the country
and not to be outdone the white house
celebrated this milestone
by spread slowing once more
and threatening to lock down the entire
country again
president biden says that we are not
returning to lockdowns
shutdowns and school closures but he
also once said that we didn't have to
wear masks anymore once we were
vaccinated so why should americans trust
him now
well because we listen to the scientists
we listen to the expert
this is a public health situation this
is not about politics at all this is
about saving lives and this is what the
president is all about he wants to make
sure
that we are saving lives if you look at
peter the last six months
that's what he's done every day and we
and you see that in the numbers
now we're at a point where we have to
double down and make it
very very clear to people that we can't
we can't let the pandemic win we have to
continue to fight so if you're listening
to the science
if scientists come to you at some point
down the line and say
it is our opinion that there should be
shutdowns and there should be school
closures
you would do that well we listened to
like i said we listened to the cdc
and the the expert and the and their
guidance
are you know are the cdc is a is a body
that is very well respected
and we file again we follow their
guidance why should we trust the
president well because he listens to the
scientists
why should we trust them they've gotten
everything wrong too meanwhile the
atlantic
magazine calls my pillow owner mike
lindell
a threat to democracy a new york times
reporter labels trump supporters
enemies of the state and nancy pelosi
orders capitol hill police
to arrest the unmasked i'm michael
knowles as the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from bo7341 who
says to be fair
i think january 6 2021 was the worst day
in american history
joe biden was confirmed as president on
that day
you know good point i guess i could have
a january 6 commission i could get
behind that
if the purpose of the commission is to
investigate how on earth we got to this
point you know
all of this madness in politics it gives
me a bit of a headache
it does it does you know what else gives
me a headache dehydration which is why i
check out
liquid iv liquid iv hydrates faster and
more efficiently than water alone
contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange as much
potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives
and less sugar than an apple that's
pretty good right it's made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan free of gluten
dairy and soy
the thing that makes it work is cellular
transport technology it's the perfect
balance
to help you hydrate more quickly and
effectively than water alone
a lot of people use this if they play
sports
if they're in athletics if they get
dehydrated that way a lot of people just
if they're walking around in the summer
it's very hot
and for some of those derelicts out
there myself included
if you have a few too many coca-colas
with the boys if you for instance go to
a bachelor party like i did a few weeks
ago
seriously liquid iv will let you survive
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquidive.com
use code michael at checkout 25 off
anything you order
when you get better hydration today
using promo code michael at
liquidity.com
i don't think anything irritates me more
in politics
than when politicians say look this
isn't political
when the white house spokesman talking
about various mandates and orders from
the president of the united states
says that those mandates and orders are
are not political
because he got the advice for them
from other politicians who work in
public health and public and politics
mean the same thing their synonyms
it's such a it's so preposterous i guess
it works i guess that's
why politicians continue to use this
rhetorical device
but sophisticated people like you would
never do this
whatever a politician does whenever a
politician does a thing that pertains to
the public and policy
it is by definition political
by the way when when private companies
do things
that affect the public broadly that is
by definition political
and what joe biden is doing is political
and it's very dishonest
and it tarnishes whatever credibility he
had left because
not so long ago joe biden said
unequivocally
if you've taken the shot then you
do not need to wear a mask if you've
been fully vaccinated
you no longer need to wear a mask
let me repeat if you are fully
vaccinated
you no longer need to wear a mask
but now you do now you do and by the way
biden and the white house has addressed
this
and what they have said is that was true
then
if you've been vaccinated you don't need
to wear a mask but it's not true now
because the words and the judgment of
the president
do not matter all that matters this is
according to them all that matters is
what
unelected technocrats in lab coats
have to say and whatever their whims and
caprices
suggest on any given day that will be
the public policy of the united states
why do we have a president i have no
idea i don't i don't really know he's
not doing anything
if if truly his public policy
just amounts to listen to the scientists
specific scientists and do whatever they
say
then we have no need for a president
and i think that is kind of the point of
the biden presidency is he is
simply a vessel for the unelected
liberal
bureaucracy biden's going further though
it's not just
yeah you should probably mask up now he
he also
wants to impel people to get the vaccine
and he knows that he probably can't do
that
at the federal level he knows he
probably can't pass a law or an
executive order that says everyone's got
to get the vaccine
so what he's doing instead is using the
so-called private companies that aren't
really private at all
and he is using them as proxies to
coerce people
to take the experimental drug why not
um push for vaccine mandates in states
private companies
schools do you want to see those
entities pass
vaccine mandates well i i'd like to see
them continue to move in that direction
and that's why
i pointed out i asked the justice
department to determine whether that is
they're able to do that legally and they
can
local communities can do that local
businesses can do that
it's still a question whether the
federal government can mandate the whole
country
i don't know that yet so that's still a
question by the way according to job i
thought it'd be a pretty simple answer
that the federal government can't
mandate the whole country take an
experimental drug
but he says that's an open question
we're working on that but in the
meantime what we're going to do is use
so-called private entities as proxies to
force you all to do it anyway this gets
to president trump's lawsuit against
facebook
and the other big tech companies he's
suing them on first amendment grounds
now usually you're only allowed to claim
a first amendment violation or it would
only carry credibility
if you're making that claim against the
government because
private companies have no responsibility
to protect your first amendment rights
but what trump is alleging is that these
private company so-called private
companies are just an extension
of the government and he makes a good
case and every time joe biden opens his
mouth he seems to make a good case
meanwhile china is spreading
disinformation on kovid
so what china's saying they've sent out
a bunch of tweets from their
propagandists
and they've said the us is responsible
for the world
uh how has the u.s poisoned the world by
the way they're like missing
it says how has u.s poisoned the world
u.s is responsible to the world
and like all this you think they educate
all of their students at american
universities you think they have a
slightly better grasp on the english
language
and they don't really but this is
obviously a
piece of propaganda to deflect blame
from the wuhan institute of virology
where the virus escaped to blame the
united states or something it is worth
pointing out that
under the lead of dr fauci the united
states actually funded the wuhan
laboratory
so i guess we bear some responsibility
in that regard
but sure enough this is misinformation
now when when i think about covet
misinformation though and we're all
putting our eye on china
i think would we ever spread
misinformation
would the u.s government ever because
you just saw the
the biden clip about the masks and you
remember seeing the dr fauci clip about
the masks and you saw the government
denying that it escaped from the wuhan
lab and then later
they said that it did and then it's so
or that it very likely did and
it seems like the united states has
spread a bit of misinformation
as well seems that the bureaucrats and
the politicians in charge in this
country
have spread a fair bit of covid
misinformation as well as a matter of
fact i think there are three groups
right now that are being called
misinformers on kovit
there's the chinese government there's
the u.s government
and then there are just random
conservatives
those are the three groups
only one of those groups gets kicked off
of twitter for spreading quote-unquote
misinformation
and ironically it's the group that tends
to be most correct
where the misinformation turns out just
to be information china goes out and
says that the united states developed
this and released it
obviously a lie they get to stay on
twitter
the us government says don't wear masks
they don't work do wear masks they do
work didn't escape
from the lab maybe it did escape from
the lab vaccines have no side effects
maybe the vegs
back and forth and back they don't get
kicked off of twitter
conservatives say huh kind of looks like
that
that wuhan virus i bet that might have
something to do with the lab
misleading misinformation i think there
might be some side effects involving
like myocarditis and
periocarditis and nerve
system disorders from the vaccine
misinformation censored
suspended for 12 hours that's a pretty
strange
state of affairs that the people who are
most correct are the only group
that are going to be censored for
stating
some plain facts
you know when i when i think about all
the threats that we face today
i am so thankful for ring ring has a
special offer right now go to ring.com
knowles that is the perfect way to start
your ring experience with rings home
security system
when anyone stops by or you sense
something going on outdoors around the
house
you know ring has every corner of your
home
covered this is one of the best benefits
of the of the whole product
you can install it yourself the process
is hassle-free it's very inexpensive i
love it to me it's just it's just peace
of mind okay whether i'm in the home
it's peace of mind
whether i'm outside the home it's peace
of mind with ring it doesn't matter if
you're at the office if you're in your
living room if you're
on a beach on the other side of the
world you can check in you can know hey
is that a burglar or is that the
delivery guy or is that the pizza guy or
is that my mother-in-law and which one
am i most afraid of i that's a real it's
a real question that only you can answer
protect your home anytime from anywhere
with ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today
build the system that's right for your
home have it up and running in minutes
ring.com knowles canon wles that is
ring.com
knowles the liberal establishment is
really ratcheting up the hysteria
is really ratcheting up the sense of
crisis and it's really ratcheting up
attacks
on political dissidents in the united
states
and i'm not just talking about a handful
of kooky dissidents on the fringe
i'm talking about half the country new
york times reporter
katie benner has just labeled
trump supporters not some trump
supporters writ large half the country
at least enemies of the state
quote today's january 6th select
committee
underscores uh the america's current the
americas
is new york times people aren't hiring
their best anymore the america's current
essential dilemma national security
dilemma
work to combat legitimate national
security threats
now entails calling a politicians
supporters
enemies of the state katie benner by the
way
covers for the times the justice
department as americans we believe that
state power should not be used to work
against a political
political figure or a political party
but
and there it is there's that butt that's
going to negate what she just said
but what happens if a politician seems
to threaten the state
if the politician continues to do so out
of office and his entire party supports
the threat
well what happens is you're going to if
you can
disingenuously but nevertheless if you
can
label your political opponents
half the country enemies of the state
then
you can more easily justify weaponizing
the full force of the federal government
against those people including the nsa
which has a foreign service
mission and yet was just caught spying
on tucker carlson
a domestic very very popular i guess
you'd call him political dissident
because he opposes the liberal regime
but it's very as mainstream as they get
he's got the highest rated show on cable
news
and yet the nsa which is only supposed
to be looking at threats outside of the
country
spying on him the fbi going after
donald trump's campaign in 2016 a
democratic party using the fbi
as its enforcement arm to spy on the
political opponents that's
that's pretty scary the jailing of
political dissonance i mean even if you
look at the the way that the
january 6th people are being treated
compared to blm
the january 6th people relatively
brought very little damage
didn't kill people the only person who
died in political violence on that day
was was
one of the trump supporters
and yet they get the book thrown at them
and they're gonna rot in prison
meanwhile blm burns down federal
courthouses and kills a bunch of people
and they get off the hook
broadly get off the hook
that is because the blm people are
considered
good useful foot soldiers for the
liberal establishment
and the trump supporters are enemies of
the state and we treat enemies of the
state differently
than we would treat foot soldiers for
the establishment
speaking of enemies of the state do you
know that insufferable cop
officer dunn the one who said he was
called all sorts of terrible names on
the basis of race he had no evidence of
this whatsoever
cameras all over the place that day
zillions of hours of video but no we
never found
any evidence of the dubious events he's
describing so officer dunn has something
to say about enemies of the state
he says that the people at the capitol
the people who
stole pelosi's lectern were much much
worse
than the blm rioters who burned the
country down first amendment protest is
what this country is about
the first amendment the constitution
like that's the democracy of it but once
you start
attacking people attacking things then
that's wrong
and that and you know what that goes to
the riots this summer
they were wrong if you peacefully
protest then sure but the riots and the
violence and the damage this summer
this they were wrong they were wrong and
that's the exact same thing that
happened at the capitol
but their goal was to overthrow
democracy
which is a bigger threat to america
wow big of you to say that that killing
dozens of people and burning down
businesses and homes and courthouses too
big of you to say that that's wrong
hey look i'm a reasonable guy okay i
think killing dozens of people is wrong
oh
thanks thanks man okay i'm glad we can
at least agree on that
but that's the exact same thing that
happened at the capitol no it's not
no it's not they're not even close
burning down city after city after city
killing person after person after person
burning down police station after police
station after federal courthouse
stealing property after property after
property and threatening to do it again
with the explicit support of
of members of the the democrat congress
and senate and the sitting vice
president now
that is not the same as making a mess of
nancy pelosi's desk it's not it's not
even close
they are completely incomparable events
and yet we're now being not only is he
saying they're the same
he's actually he's actually then later
saying what happened at the capitol is
worse because they want to overthrow
democracy
burning down a courthouse that's federal
gordos that's not overthrowing democracy
burning down the symbol of the justice
system that's that's not overthrowing
democracy
but jumping up and down with a horn hat
on that is
pathetic pathetic so what are we going
to do about it
we're just going to complain right
that's what we're going to do i think
the only people who are who are doing
their job
in in this entire fiasco and i hate to
toot my own horn
but it's those of us on the communicator
side of it it's those of us
in the conservative media it's those and
i'm not saying
look i think it'd be much better if
legislators were actually taking action
or judges were taking action or people
with real hard political power were
taking action
but all we can do if you have a
microphone all you can do is call
attention to this stuff that the
mainstream media won't talk about
all you can do is call attention to not
only what's happening in the news
but what that what that relates to from
a philosophical perspective from a
historical perspective you can provide
context
you can lay out the plan of what to do
but
if you're not sitting in congress if
you're not sitting in the senate
if you're not a legislator if you're not
in the bureaucracy if you're not a judge
then you don't have that hard political
power to do something
so do something do something guys
thankfully
some congressmen or finally do some
doing something very important here
representatives jim jordan and kathy
mcmorris rogers
are now introducing legislation finally
finally thank you guys for doing this
when i don't know why
other republicans hadn't done this yet
to amend section
230 of the communications decency act
you know this
is the provision of the cda
which would give legal protections
liability protections to big tech
companies and allows them to
act as publishers but then claim that
they're not publishers and basically
just allows them to censor
you and political dissidence and and the
president of the united states for that
matter
who ironically is a kind of political
dissident when the entire
political order is run by the liberal
establishment
the communications decency act which
ironically
was gutted by the supreme court and the
central provision the anti-indecency
provisions the whole point of the
cda was to control pornography on the
internet
in the early days of the internet and
that central provision was gutted
by libs on the supreme court and so that
but
but this section 230 has remained and so
uh
this is great stuff uh you know section
230 stipulates that quote no provider or
user of an interactive computer service
shall be treated as the publisher or
speaker of any information provided by
another information content provider
this would this law
or this you know this bill that's being
proposed by jordan and rogers
would exempt certain gigantic big tech
companies from this sort of protection
it's a good step in the right direction
because the entire establishment right
now is trying to criminalize
conservative thought exhibit a
the atlantic the atlantic and applebaum
whose well-known
political writer she has a peace out
called
the my pillow guy really could destroy
democracy
so mike lindell you know my pillow
a company that has supported this show
and many many other conservative shows
he could destroy democracy a very nice
guy patriotic guy very inspiring story
he could apparently destroy democracy
if democracy
can be destroyed by a pillow salesman
then democracy was probably not all that
sturdy in the first place
okay and and i i just want to reiterate
here
when anne applebaum
nancy pelosi or kamala harris or anybody
else
refer to our democracy
they are not referring to democracy none
of these people like democracy
all of these people are progressives the
point of progressivism is to make the
country
less democratic to take political power
away from the people
to upend the constitutional order and
give it to bureaucrats
biden and biden's spokesman said it
clearly we
follow the science we don't follow the
judgment and prudence of the people we
don't follow
the constitution in many places we
follow whatever the egghead bureaucrats
tell us
they don't like democracy as angelo
cotavillo
says very well when they refer to
our democracy they are actually
referring
to their oligarchy okay so please
spare me the crocodile tears over our
democracy when you're trying
you are casting a perfectly patriotic
inspiring american citizen all he's ever
done is sell pillows
you're casting him as an enemy of the
people
you know mike lindell is a really nice
mustache it's really it's very very
impressive it's one of these sort of you
know
like 80s 90s cool mustaches if you want
to grow some facial hair
i strongly recommend you check out beard
supply the july and august heat
is upon us if you're trying to grow
one of those matt walsh beards one of
those jeremy boring beards
if you want to get that just sprouting
out of your out of your face
you're going to want to keep it tamed
you're going to want to keep it looking
fresh you don't want to look like some
absolute maniac no matter how humid or
dry your summer is turning out to be
that's why you need a beard oil from
beard supply if you're one of these men
that are currently growing or
maintaining a beard chances are you need
those products to keep it looking thick
and healthy
don't show up to the neighborhood
barbecue without a bit of beard oil to
keep your beard in check
okay go to beardsupply.com because for a
limited time only you can buy one beard
oil product and get another one
for free you go check out our friends
over at beardsupply.com
order yourself two beard oils for the
price of one
you can mix and match different scents
or stock up on an old classic whatever
you choose
make sure you choose beard supply beard
supply dot com buy one beard oil get
another one
for free not to be outdone
in the hyperbolic rhetoric and
overreaction against the
unwashed masses now they're called the
unvaccinated
or the unmasked nancy pelosi
has ordered the capitol hill police to
arrest
visitors and staff members of committees
and united states congressmen who are
not wearing masks in the capitol
there are two houses right there are two
chambers there's the house of
representatives and the senate
both are controlled by the democrats
right now in the democrat controlled
senate
you do not need to wear a mask there's
no mask mandate you won't be fined it's
cool so a democratic senator can just
walk around without a mask on
it's fine or republican senator or
anyone else
if you're in the house of
representatives you'll be fined 500
every time that you do not wear a mask
if you're a member of congress
and if you're a staff member or a
visitor you will be
arrested i'm glad at least that pelosi
has
stopped short of arresting house members
might look a little bit like an
insurrection wouldn't you say
might look a little bit like a coup huh
how ironic so she stopped short of that
for now but this of course has nothing
to do with
science and this has nothing to do with
stopping the spread of coronavirus
on the very day that nancy pelosi
decided to start enforcing this measure
of
arresting people for goodness sakes if
if they're not wearing masks in the
capitol
nancy pelosi was spotted and
photographed
at a crowded event not wearing
a mask the event was outside but it was
very crowded
it was very very crowded and by the way
pelosi is ordering the masks to be worn
all over the capitol ground so it's not
even that it's only
in certain rooms or anything like that
and she violated her own order
or her own principle the same day
but it doesn't matter no one really
believes that this matters
as in terms of public health these
people
just want to impose their will it's
politically advantageous they took a lot
of power from people and they're not
going to give it back
as some of us warned last year
when there were some conservatives who
went a little squishy i got to tell you
they went a little squishy on the masks
and they said oh it's okay it's a
reasonable measure and it'll help us get
back to normal it won't
it won't it is the symbol of the power
that the left took from you we need
to go on offense here's a here's a great
new bill that was introduced it's
probably not going to go anywhere but
it's a great new bill this is what i'm
talking about
when i say offense ronald reagan had a
great line he said when you're
explaining you're losing
you might have every perfect explanation
in the world because you did something
or because you said something but it
doesn't matter if you're the one on
defense explaining
then you're losing we need to put the
left
on defense so representative michael
waltz from florida
has introduced legislation meant to
promote financial transparency
within the biden and harris immediate
families because of hunter biden hunter
biden
who is this influence-peddling criminal
who
has traded on his father's name and sold
his father's influence to the highest
bidder around the world to ukraine
to china he tried to sell it to china
he's made a lot a lot of money on this
merely selling his name in industries
that he has
absolutely no expertise and whatsoever
so
now hunter biden is a painter he calls
himself a professional painter
his work is actually not by the
standards of modern art
so i'm damning with faint praise it's
not terrible but it's not good it looks
it's like something a third grader could
do so hunter
biden is now a painter and he's selling
his
very bad paintings for half a million
dollars a pop
hmm do you do you think that the
anonymous buyers of these paintings do
you think they just really have an
appreciation for the little doodles that
hunter's doing
or do you think maybe they're trying to
buy influence
which is the the real industry that
hunter biden's worked in his entire life
so representative waltz introduced
the preventing anonymous income by
necessitating
transparency of executive relatives act
or because you know washington loves an
acronym the painter act
really great stuff it's it's a bit harsh
actually it says that
these relatives need to report the
source and type of earned income
exceeding a thousand dollars
and the source and type of any honoraria
received more than two hundred dollars
and so it's actually the uh source and
type of income from rents and dividends
and interest in capital gains
over 200 so that's you know that's a
very low threshold for earnings and
but it doesn't matter the law is not
going to go through i just love
i love the name i love the angle i love
the point of it i actually wish
a similar law would go through and i
like that we're on offense i like that
we're calling attention
to hold on a sec i don't why are you
still talking about trump look at what
the bidens are doing
look at their corruption this is how i
feel about the january 6th commission
is why are we talking about january 6th
when when blm burned the country down
with the encouragement of leftists and
democrats for
for six to eight months speaking of
going on offense
really really great stuff from
professors robbie george
and john finis these are two
conservative scholars
professors they filed an amicus brief
uh in this dobbs case you know this is
the case i've mentioned a few times on
the show it's the one that seeks to
overturn roe v
wade and to overturn planned parenthood
v casey and to say there's no
constitutional right to an abortion
which obviously there isn't
so they filed a brief for the court to
give them context
arguing not just that
you know if if roe v wade is overturned
that then the question goes back to the
states and the states can decide if they
want
to have abortion or not have abortion
right that's been the kind of
conservative talking point for the last
few decades they're going further
robbie george and john finnish are going
further and they're saying
actually the 14th amendment when it was
ratified
was understood to consider
unborn children as persons and if unborn
children are persons
then they have the right not to be
killed without due process
so it goes further it's not just that
the abortion question goes back to the
states
it goes further to say that
abortion is illegal it's obviously
unjust it's obviously immoral and it's
prohibited by the 14th amendment
i love this kind of offense i love this
kind of aggression
really really good stuff from these
professors is it going to have an effect
on the case
i don't know i don't think it's going to
give us this result in the case but i
think what conservatives need to start
doing
is arguing past the sale don't just ask
for what you want just
don't just demand what you want go
further go way way way further so that
when you start to
reconcile when you start to compromise
then you can go back to what you really
want donald trump was really good at
this
the democrats are really good at this
and and republicans need to get much
better at this as well
the authoritarian moment not just my
campaign in 2028 but ben's new book is
available at barnes noble amazon and
other major book sellers so you can go
get your copy now
leave a five-star review to let others
know that this book is worth their time
it's a great book to buy
right after you buy speechless number
one national best-selling book
appreciate all of you who have read it
so far i really liked too so many of you
were sending in reviews of the book
and telling me that you really liked it
so i appreciate that very much
if you've watched backstage and you
thought hey it'd be cool to be part of
that show
then i'm here to tell you now is your
chance when you join the daily wire with
code backstage you get 25
off your membership and are
automatically entered to win a trip to
visit the daily wire in nashville
head on over to dailywire.com backstage
and use code backstage to get 25
off your new membership and be
automatically entered to win not one but
two
tickets to our studios that's
dailywire.com backstage
use code backstage to get 25 off your
new membership we'll be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question from
marisa who says i recently heard that
yoga
is actually bad and demonic i have never
heard this before and enjoy yoga on the
occasion
for both exercise and relaxation in a
world with constant stimulation i find
it nice to relax and clear your thoughts
as you're doing yoga
there is the old saying an idol mind is
the devil's playground and is that why
yoga is bad
why does something that brings me
relaxation why is it detrimental to my
soul sincerely
namaste whatever noel says is right is
probably right
wow great great sign off
yes it is i
i was trying to figure out if i could
sugarcoat it or no it's just it is bad
and it almost certainly is demonic and
you shouldn't do it
okay why because yoga is not just
stretching stretching is fine meditating
actually is fine
clearing your thoughts and having
stillness prayer is certainly fine
but yoga is not just that yoga is a
religious ritual it is it is
a hindu liturgy that's where it comes
from and hinduism has all sorts of
different gods that it worships that are
not
the god of christianity okay and it has
all sorts of spiritual aspects and it's
got the chanting and the humming and the
the focusing and it it falls into a
number of
theological errors pretty dangerous ones
some of some of one of them for instance
would be monism the idea that
everything is just one right every it's
all the universe man and we're part of
the universe and we're part of the
creation and god is kind of part it's
all just the same thing man
you know we're all just going back into
that same thing that is a very popular
idea in new age it's popular in
non-theistic religions but it's
not christian the christian idea is that
and the jewish idea and the muslim idea
is that there is god
and then god the creator makes the
creation and we are part of creation so
we have a
close relationship to god and we are
made in the image of god but we are not
all just one man we
there actually are distinct things it
also falls into the heresy
of gnosticism that if you just you know
if you just sort of think certain things
and you know certain truths that that
and you just kind of meditate on that
that you'll be able to transcend the
world and that's
very important um you know
i understand we're getting into sort of
subtle distinctions here
but that is not not a christian idea
this this gnostic idea that's associated
with uh with yoga same thing with this
sort of technical idea of yoga that if
you
put your body in certain positions this
is going to unlock certain spiritual
fruits
this technical aspect is also not not
exactly christian
um but but even just the the basic fact
that it is a liturgy from
another religion that is rather
different and contradictory toward your
religion
is why you shouldn't do it if you want
to stretch and relax i recommend pilates
and meditation
and prayer from sarah hey michael i
started dating a guy
almost a year ago and things have been
going really well we're extremely
compatible i think we both helped each
other improve his people
i love him to death and i wouldn't trade
him for anything there's only one
problem
he's an atheist and i'm a christian i've
been able to ignore this problem thus
far
as people have started mentioning
marriage he seems to be nowhere near
converting
and it's become abundantly clear that i
need to address this do you think it's
acceptable for me to continue with this
relationship if not
how do i approach him about this thanks
for the help sincerely facing the
atheist factor trademark
tough problem that you're in
it depends on your place in life when
sweet little elise and i started dating
you know back in the carter
administration back when we were like
two years old you know we dated in high
school we've known each other since we
were 10 or 11 years old
so back in those days we had very
different political use very different
religious views i told you i was an
atheist for a decade or so and so we've
grown together you either grow together
you grow apart
and if you're you know 16 years old or
something and
you've got these different views i
wouldn't worry so much about it because
you're still
educating yourself you're still changing
you're evolving you're going to grow
together
very likely if you're 30 and you're
really looking seriously at marriage
right now and you guys just have these
really set
views that are that are not likely to
change all that much
then that becomes a real problem in no
small part because
theoretically your husband will be the
head of household right and so how do
you have a marriage
where the husband has this just
completely false
view of the world and where he he he
if he assumes a leadership role is going
to lead your family on the most
important matters in these spiritual
matters
in the wrong direction and if he doesn't
assume a leadership role that's a
problem too
so so i i think it is going to come to a
head it's a tough
tough issue for you but
he's got to get it in order and he he's
going to
he's going to have to make some hard
decisions i think or you're going to
give up your faith but you will grow
together or you will grow apart
and if if he's not going to come see the
fullness of truth then
then you're you're in for a bad you're
in for a bad conclusion either way
from anders unders undes greetings and
salutations
to he who knows much i've been watching
your show for a little over a year now
and have been intrigued by your faith a
lot of religious questions today there
always are
i grew up as a member of a christian
household but in recent years have
fallen away and lost interest in the
church mainly because of the lack of
leadership there that being said my
question is this in your mind is there a
difference between protestantism and
catholicism if so are the two
irreconcilable
i find the tenets of catholicism
attractive but was raised to think of it
as a kind of false doctrine
sincerely he who knows little but seeks
much there's a great book on this point
for people who you know i was not raised
protestant so i didn't have those
problems though i
on my way back from atheism i spent a
lot of time reading protestants
and really appreciating i mean some
protestants were actually very important
in my reversion to the faith
but ultimately i did not remain in the
protestant world i i reverted to
catholicism i do think that's
the true faith and you know i obviously
i think there's a distinction i've made
my choice
there's a good book uh called rome sweet
home which is a book
about uh people who are either
fundamentalist especially
or just protestant more broadly uh and
answering some issues about catholicism
it has been said that that there are not
a hundred people in this country
who hate the catholic church but there
are millions of people who hate what
they believe to be the catholic church
they just
are you know have been taught wrong i
mean you'll hear a lot of these things
that
catholics worship mary and the saints
which is not true or catholics believe
that you earn your salvation which is
you know that you achieve your salvation
through your own effort exclusively that
obviously is not true
uh that uh catholics worship idols that
obviously is not true and
and these debates go back 2000 years and
there are many more sophisticated people
who have written on them and and settled
them than
you or i or many people writing today so
i would encourage you to do that i would
encourage you to check out resources
like catholic answers
great great website and and media
company i would recommend that you check
out the patrick madrid show it's a
wonderful podcast and
a radio show friend of mine patrick
madrid my friend patrick coffin great
great too he's
he's a little more for the already
initiated you know but but still very
very uh terrific
broadcaster but patrick madrid i think
could could really help answer
some of these questions and uh
i think they're irreconcilable
until the church comes back together in
the end which i suspect will happen but
beyond the the issue of the place of
mary and of the saints and of the
episcopacy and the
bishops and the pope and all beyond all
that i think the central
issue here is one if you believe in the
divine institution of a real church by a
real guy who's
incarnate then and you believe that the
apostles really did receive certain uh
graces and you believe that they really
did choose their replacements and you
believe that there is a line and there
is history and there's a continuity to
this institution
uh i think that leads one in the
direction of the catholic church
and also on a philosophical level
if you believe that there's the physical
world
and the metaphysical world and they seem
very separate right this this world that
we're living in and then the
supernatural
the outside of physical and you believe
that
sometimes they come together most
perfectly in the person of christ
who is fully man but also fully god
and somehow he's together in this
hypostatic union
if you believe that and you believe that
he institutes sacraments
you know he he says you have the power
to forgive sins who sends you for giver
forgiven who sins you retain or retained
you have the keys to the kingdom of
heaven he says this to peter the first
pope you have the keys to the kingdom of
heaven
and the gates of hell will not will not
uh
prevail against my church and go feed my
sheep and all of these sorts of things
if you believe in the institution of the
eucharist that they're
this the the eucharist really is the
body and blood of christ
then what you're saying at a
philosophical level is
mankind requires the regular
meeting of the physical and the
metaphysical
and we know that we do because we're
physical beings but we're also
metaphysical beings and we need that
regular communion with between those two
things then i think the place you're
going to find that is the catholic
church
your mileage may vary of course but but
that would be one of my arguments
from ben hi michael there is a lot of
talk about the flaws of america and
other western countries where they
criticize and are allowed to complain
at a nauseous level my question is
which country would you least desire to
live in if you could also exclude
only one basically in 2021 which country
would be a bleephole country
would win the bleephole country medal at
the olympics thanks sincerely came for
the beer and blue jeans stayed for the
beer and blue jeans hashtag america
i think afghanistan would be the place
i'd least like to live
it is historically one of the most
dangerous poor tumultuous countries
no one seems able to conquer it i guess
that's something it has going for it but
seems seems like a tough place to live
and uh pretty strange that the united
states has been there for 20 years
it's 20 years now isn't that isn't that
wild but that's probably where i i mean
no offense to the afghani people
but it does not seem pleasant
of course according to the left america
is no better than afghanistan in some
ways were worse
from archie michael what is your
favorite brand of sockless loafers and
where do you stand on tassels my
favorite brand on sock
of sockless loafers i'm not even being
paid to advertise in this rank horton
company from maine
my thoughts on tassels or they're a
little more old school i'm not quite i
don't have quite enough gray hairs yet i
prefer the penny loafer
but i'll wear tassels on occasion from
jared dear michael my wife is not a
citizen yet
we're working on the paperwork though
she informed me recently that one of her
relatives is here on a student visa
and is planning to let the visa lapse
and just stay here illegally as a
christian and a conservative i feel very
strong loyalty to my family
but i also feel a duty to do something
about this lest i be a hypocrite in
discussions of illegal immigration
what can i do to remedy this dissonance
sincerely in a vin diesel voice
i don't need ice i got family that's
uh tough tough predicament you're in but
i actually think there's a pretty
straight answer
you should state your views on the
matter
both to your wife to your wife's
relative that to
anyone who is interested in listening
but i don't think you should rat this
relative out to the cops i don't think
that would be the right thing to do i
think
perhaps you should persuade this
relative to leave the country and then
if she wants to move here or to do that
in a legal way but i don't think it is
your obligation or your duty
or really even your place to call the
cops
and and have your relative deported
especially as the immigration law is not
being forced
even by law enforcement i don't think it
would do anything frankly you know we're
letting
we've already led a million illegal
aliens into the country so for this year
there's no chance there's no
no evidence that they're going to slow
down so i just think
you know nobody likes a tattletale and
so what you can do is
is work on a personal level but i don't
think that you need to
be the uh the tattletail and the
enforcement arm of ice
even ice is not the enforcement arm of
ice from nick
in 1984 the slogan wars peace uh lends
to the idea
that the party can use international war
for the purpose of domestic peace
but what would you say that our party
or what would you say that our party is
using a domestic culture war to
establish peace
within the shifting political landscape
via slate of hand from nick
the happily married one good this is not
the nick who i like that other nick too
but he's got that guy's got problems
sometimes
uh so to the to the more stable nick
i think you're catching on to something
what what you are asking if i understood
your question correctly is
is the republican party just ginning up
people's opinions in the culture war
without any intention of ever
resolving the issues because actually
they benefit so
for instance on pro-life i suspect that
there are many
conservatives and republicans who don't
really want to move the needle on
abortion
they just they actually would prefer to
keep abortion a live issue because they
can fundraise on it
and and it actually helps them
politically yeah i think that's true
and i've i've talked with various people
on
capitol hill who who have told me as
much that there were some squishier
republicans who
they actually don't really want anything
to happen on abortion they just they
just like fundraising from it
it's too bad but that's the way it works
and i think probably we've got to do a
better job of
chasing those people out of office all
right final question
from jessica conservatives have a very
traditional view of women in the world
where traditional has become synonymous
with sexist and malignant
they have infiltrated the minds of women
and men seemingly placing a higher value
on masculine qualities such as monetary
success and success outside the home
shouldn't the rights focus beyond
redefining success and happiness
our or focus on showing the feminine
qualities are different rather than less
than respectfully null splaining over
mansplaining
you are so right my dear you are so
right jessica
what the right often does is
accepts the left's premises and then
impotently
sort of tries to argue against them
don't accept the premises
fight back push hard get aggressive or
else we're going to be here not on the
500th
day to slow the sprint we're going to be
here on the thousandth day the 1500th
day the 2000th day
i'll see you next time i'm michael
nolsas the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico associate producer justine
turley
audio mixer mike coromina and hair and
makeup by nika geneva
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 john bickley here editor-in-chief
of daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire on today's episode
president biden addresses immigration
and crime
countries around the world loosen their
travel restrictions and democrats push
for student loan forgiveness
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire